now to the business of will smith's
oscar fate in less than 24 hours the
academy is expected to hand down their
final decision as former oscar hosts
billy crystal and amy schumer speak out
it was an assault everybody was just
kind of floored what we saw was terribly
distressing it really felt like the
situation room we were all just like
watching the monitor and we're like and
then he won
love will make you do crazy things
well the big question now how if at all
will the academy punish will smith after
they've accepted his resignation we'll
know more tomorrow that's when the
academy's board of governors meets to
decide his fate a zoom call is scheduled
for 9am the board includes some big
stars whoopi goldberg laura dern and
rita wilson and some famous directors
ava duvernay and steven spielberg
it might surprise you just how closely
connected will is to some of the academy
members who will be on that zoom their
screenwriter eric roth who worked on the
script for ali will got an oscar nom for
the role will is you know i mean a
mentor and a friend
producer and academy vice president
devon franklin interned for will more
than two decades ago last year he told
me the oscar winner has been a huge
positive influence in terms of helping
me do the work that i need to do as a
man to be a better man to be a better
husband academy president david rubin
was the casting director for two big
will smith movies men in black and wild
wild west and by the way spielberg
produced men in black and convinced will
to do the movie
whatever the outcome will has said he is
ready to fully accept any and all
consequences
[Laughter]
the tone of that it was so angry and it
was so violent we spoke to
oscar-nominated songwriter diane warren
last night she said the moment still
seems surreal i literally said was that
real what what was that it was too bad
but chris rock was a champ you know he
was awesome wouldn't he be the perfect
host nice dear